Young was so radical thinker.
It's just beyond belief.
Like I've read a lot of critics of young and I've always,
I've always got a kick out of them because the things they accused young of are
so trivial compared to the things that young actually did that it's like
accusing a murderer of jaywalking.
Like because young was unbelievably radical.
Like here's one of his ideas,
you know,
he thought that it was necessary.
He believed that psychotherapy could be replaced by a supreme moral effort.
And so the moral effort would be something like aiming at the good and then
trying to integrate yourself around that and that
the good at which you aimed would be something approximating what you would be
like if you manifested your full potential and that you'd have a glimmering of
what that for full potential was.
So that would be the potential future you and he thought of that.
He thought of people as four dimensional entities,
especially essentially that we're stretched across time and that you as a
totality across time,
including your potential manifested yourself also in the here and now.
And that part of what your potential manifested itself was something like the
voice of conscious conscience or intuition.
It's amazing idea.
It's an amazing idea,
right?
Because it's like what you could be in the future beckons to you in the present
and helps you determine the difference between good and evil.
It's a mind boggling idea.
And you know,
I think that it's an idea you have to contend with.
And then he went further than that.
And this is,
this is also remarkable idea.
You know,
he was interested in this symbolic representation of Christ and I mean
psychologically speaking,
and he thought of Christ as the representation of the ideal potential human.
It's something like that.
So it was a symbolic at,
at minimum,
that's what Christ was,
is a symbolic representation of the ideal potential of a human being.
And so for young,
there was no difference between,
there was no psychological difference between who you could be in the future
beckoning to you and the prey in the present and orienting yourself in
relationship to Christ.
Psychologically.
Those were the same thing.
And then so that's a pretty mind boggling idea.
Like seriously,
that's a mind boggling idea.
You know,
especially when you add the psychological idea that one of the things that
characterizes your ideal future self is the ability to make sacrifices,
right?
And the deeper the sacrifice,
the better.
And then also to recover from the sacrifice,
right?
So that's the death and rebirth.
So the part of you that's most essential to your full flowering as a,
as a being is your ability to let things go and then spring back from that.
So to die in some sense and to be reborn in the service of a higher good.
And then,
well then the next part of that is that the direction of the world depends on
doing that.
So not only your own life,
but your family's life.
And,
and because we're networked so intently together,
you know,
the whole panoply of humankind,
and maybe the structure of the,
of the cosmos.
And,
you know,
you might think,
well,
no,
but you know,
it's not so simple.
It's not so simple.